David how should we actually deal with
police brutality okay in this segment
I'm not going to argue about what
percentage of cops are good or bad or
try to quantify the degree to which
police brutality and racialized policing
is a problem it is a problem even listen
Rush Limbaugh said things that were
bought you know for Rush Limbaugh
standards conceding that we have a
problem with policing in this country on
The Breakfast Club earlier this week
Kellyanne Conway said it now Kellyanne
Conway also said and Trump is dealing
with it that's a lie I'm not gonna argue
about the degree to which it's a problem
it's a problem there are many issues
with policing that need to be solved it
doesn't matter if 92 or 94 percent of
police are good or whether it's 99.1
versus ninety nine point three percent
we've got a lot of issues that need to
be solved so here are some ideas from
the point of so there's the legal side
and there's the the behavior side let's
talk first about how police behave we
need to be looking at training and a lot
of the infrastructure that's there so
police training in the United States
should be completely reworked for lack
of a better term if you look at many
other countries officers train much
longer before they are just sent out to
be police okay now there are gonna be
arguments about it costs too much or the
I'm telling you what should be done then
we figure out how to make it happen and
by the way we found six trillion bucks I
think we can find a way to better train
police if we decide we want to do it
Germany as an example trains police much
longer the United States sometimes
you've got like a 12 or 13 week training
program and then you're out there
sometimes it's you know six months or
whatever police training needs to be
longer and a lot more of the training
needs to be more the type of training
that social workers get academic stuff
based on the principles that you would
learn if you were studying for a master
in Social Work because you prevent a lot
of crime what it straight out just you
prevent having to deal with crime then
we'll get to how you how do you deal
with crime you prevent a lot of crime if
you have police that are properly
trained
as social workers in addition there's a
lot of stuff that's not actually
criminal or it's marginally criminalized
as misdemeanors that can or cannot be
enforced based on the discretion of
officers we're if you have officers
better trained in de-escalation you have
officers better trained with some of
these soft skills as we might call them
you reduce the number of interactions
that become problematic
number two we need more extensive
psychological and personality testing of
police and we want to just make sure
we're bringing in the right people again
most cops are good some like Trump
admitted on Twitter they're looking for
action there's a sort of bloodlust in
some fraction of police officers those
officers understand this and I don't I
don't want to get off topic here the bad
apples the bad eggs don't just typically
do one bad thing they do a whole bunch
so a huge portion of the over overuse of
force complaints and other bad acts are
concentrated among a small number of
repeat police offenders if we did a
better job of evaluating and psych
testing and personality testing police
we could root out a lot of the problem
by never hiring that small percentage
that wants to get out there and slap
people around and is looking to get the
riot gear and do what we've seen being
done on videos so route them out with it
more psychological and personality
testing there should probably be some
established process for civilian review
of shoot police shootings and uses of
force it can't just be left to police
departments to investigate because we
all know that there are many police
chiefs that are doing this properly we
know that there are internal internal
affairs boards that are operating more
or less okay we should probably have
more civilian involvement in review of
police shootings and uses of force we've
got to demilitarize the militarization
of police forces has been a huge problem
I've talked about that on its own so I
won't delve too much into that and there
should probably be a national database
of bad police actors because it would
prevent two things number one there's a
national database of bad actors people
police officers with a
number of complaints against them it
would prevent officers from hiding prior
complaints by simply not reporting them
when they're trying to get hired at a
new Police Department because there
would be a national database so
reporting to the database should be
mandatory but also if you're hiring a
police officer if you're not bringing
them through police academy and you're
giving them their first police job it
should be a requirement that police
departments have to check with that
central database so that the police
department can't get away with saying we
didn't know we just didn't know because
it would be a requirement to report
complaints to the database and to look
at the database if you are hiring
someone now then you've got prosecution
in terms of prosecution decisions on
prosecution of police officers and the
prosecution itself meaning the trials it
should be happening
ideally outside the county where the
incidents took place it can be very
difficult to get what we would all call
a fair trial fair to the victims fair to
the officers fair to everybody fair to
the community when a lot of these cases
are being tried inside the jurisdiction
now by the jurist it might be outside of
the town but still in the county and on
a lot of America that's not far enough
that's another thing that should should
be done you've got to try and prosecute
these cases outside
realistically of the county where they
took place some ideas there are many
more I'd love to hear from you